metals that fracture like an eggshell
rubber that fractures like glass this
isn't fiction this is actually how
materials can behave sometimes and it
can sometimes get us into trouble hi my
name is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to my lab
at Yale University and to a special
edition of science explained on the
Titanic when the Titanic made its maiden
voyage from England to New York it was
struck by it iceberg off the coast of
Newfoundland and sank the tail of the
Titanic points to the iceberg as the
sole villain but that's not the case
there were other culprits as well you
see the story of the Titanic is actually
a story about materials materials can
change their properties based on the
temperatures that they experience let's
look at this in action here I have a
rubber hose the rubber is very pliable
and stretchy however let's look at a
piece of rubber that's experienced
liquid nitrogen temperatures it no
longer acts like rubber but it acts like
a glass
so you can see materials will change
their property significantly based on
the temperatures that they experienced
and it's this glass transition that
rubber can experience that actually was
the cause for the accident for the space
shuttle Challenger now metals too can
change their properties they can become
ductile or flexible too brittle just
like an eggshell when the Titanic was in
seawater the seawater was 28 degrees
Fahrenheit or minus 2 degrees Celsius
these temperatures are colder than
freezing now had the Titanic been in
slightly warmer waters the metal would
have been ductile so a collision with
the iceberg would have caused a dent or
buckling sort of like you would see in a
car accident
but at those frigid temperatures the
metal acted like it was more like an
eggshell now let's look at this behavior
in action I want to show you how you can
drastically change a metals properties
based on the temperature experiences now
this is not exactly what happened to the
Titanic but you'll see a drastic effect
here I have a bobby pin it's made out of
high carbon steel and it's very very
flexible let's see what happens when I
heat this up and then cool it very
quickly all right let's do that I'm
going to heat it to red-hot with this
blow torch and then we're going to
quench it in the water let's see what
happens see it's red-hot quench it in
the water now let's see what happens if
we pull this apart wow that took almost
nothing from a science point of view
that's really cool but from an
engineering and design point of view
that's pretty unfortunate so you see
that materials can change their
properties based on the temperatures
that they experience
now there's also new theories that point
to the rivets the rivets of the Titanic
there are over 3 million of these rivets
that held the Titanic together now the
way that they made rivets back then was
very different from the way that we made
rivets today back then they had lots of
impurities lots of junk in it and lots
of junk in a rivet actually makes the
rivet very weak a weak rivet means that
we have weak joints between the sheets
that are holding the Titanic to get
and so in a collision something would
just unzip so as you can see materials
were a great factor in the Titanic the
tale of the Titanic is really about
understanding materials had the
engineers back then known what we've
known now perhaps there would have been
many more survivors we know now that the
temperatures that materials experienced
affect their properties and with the
many advances that we've made in
materials today an event like the
Titanic never would have been in history
I'm Aneesa Ramirez thank you for joining
me in my lab and I hope you'll join us
for another edition of science explained